[Applause]
uh i think it's just crazy i think being
at your courses is just on another level
you walk through the door and you just
leave as a different person
you leave as a machine
[Music]
what's been the hardest the hardest
moment in germany
hey what's up my name is samuel leeson
in this interview i want to bring a
guest to you who is killing it in
property he has rent to rent serviced
accommodation pieces of land out in the
caribbean he's buying houses pulling
money out all across the uk and in this
interview you're gonna learn exactly how
he's doing it and how you can do the
same thing too most people spend their
whole life wanting to get on the
property ladder buying one houses maybe
two this guy's buying houses bang bang
bang super fast and there's a secret to
it and in this video you're gonna learn
that secret so stay tuned smash the like
button and subscribe so arneldo welcome
to my home thank you thank you samuel
it's an honor to be here and you know
it's like i'm still pinching myself as
to where am i and i remember when i
started just watching your youtube
videos and i'm watching other people on
winners on a wednesday and i'm actually
sitting here now
it can't be real but it's well deserved
man because you've worked super hard
over the last sort of how long you've
been on the academy now like seven eight
months yes i've been on the economy for
seven months now um and it's just been
an amazing ride and it's not over still
killing it so of all the strategies that
you're doing
which one is your favorite strategy
uh i would say buy refurbished refinance
um and rent um i don't sell any of my
properties i keep them on um because you
know my mentor samuel you've told me you
know cash flow is king um so i want to
be getting that cash flow back i'm not
into paying tax i'm not looking to sell
anything but dude we were just together
last week at the training program and
just that week you'd bank secured a rent
to rent which now you're waiting on the
contracts to complete on i think it's
just crazy i think being at your courses
is just on another level and anyone who
hasn't been down to your courses yet
need to really get down there i think
you you walk through the door and you
just leave as a different person you
leave as a machine
and you just leave it the confidence
where you can just walk into you know
any estee agency or literally speaking
to anyone confident confident confident
yeah
you know and it's just amazing
absolutely amazing so you from the
caribbean i was born and raised in sin
vincent i moved to the uk in 2008 i
started in the british army until 2012.
i left and i started a career in it um
and then obviously
worked doing good part side by side
doing property think about you as well i
love training people like you because
you've got a massive heart you've
already set a charity up you're giving
back um tell me a little bit about that
and then i want to get onto the property
stuff and how you're doing what you're
doing and stuff but tell me about your
charity yeah sure so
i know you know again listening to my
mentor it's always something that comes
at the end for people who become
financially free and want to give back
to the community and to the academy i
was also a bit rushed into that process
because we had a volcano that erupted
and as you said having the heart i have
i've gone on to create a charity to
support those people
um and since the volcano erupted we've
been sending donations back to saint
vincent we've sent 440 foot containers
at the moment wow even running the
charity on the side that's that's
something else um and also you know
balancing that work
and obviously i'm studying huge bro well
congrats talk me through i want to know
the figures of your first deal how did
you structure it how did you finance it
i wonder all about that first deal
because i know that's where it started
last year with that little brr so how
did you find that yeah so so the first
property i bought um after you know
having all of that excitement from going
to the bureau of course um was up in
durham um i bought that for forty seven
thousand bang
and you're you you live in high victims
that must have felt like the cheapest
house purchase ever exactly compared to
properties that you know obviously we
fight on this end and it was such a
difference and so that was put it for 47
000 we did a full refurb on it that cost
him 19 000. um esther agent said to me
she reckons they'll be valued over a
hundred thousand obviously we got value
done valued on it for ninety thousand
didn't really care because we managed to
put our money out anyway hey that's been
absolutely crazy amazing so so for
anyone that doesn't understand how this
works so you bought it for 47 and you
spent 19 on it so all in all 66 grand
cash
how did you find that that was did you
use your own money other people's money
bridging how did you how did you do that
yeah sure so that was used out of my own
money um we had a bit of savings and
also um we refinance our home as well
show them after coming on another one of
your courses that teaches you how to
find money that you already have right
um so
you know we just use that to our
advantage because i think people might
think oh it's all right for you you have
66 grand in the bank but it might not be
in the bank it might be that you've got
the 66 grand which you can actually
borrow against your house
so so you've got to find ways to tap
into money so you bought the house for
cash you spent all the money on the
refurb 66 grand all in but then the new
value was 90. that's correct which you
felt was unfair
but still you managed to then refinance
so how does the refinance process where
how do you refinance a home that you've
already bought
it's quite easy as as we're taught i am
you know obviously because we're buying
that property cash or for someone else
who are buying it with bridging loan
yeah um
you know you might have property cash in
and you obviously get a mortgage after
you've done the works you uplift the
value then you put your money back up
once you get the new value how did you
find that property then was it like a
lucky find or what happened uh so that
one was bought at auction um i was
literally looking looking looking
it was a tough time in the market and i
saw that property i went to view it um i
knew the figures were going to work out
and then i literally just
just put myself and i think auction's
such a powerful way to buy property it's
fast there's no messing yeah did you
complete on that in one month yeah
literally within 28 days um i had the
property and i already done my like in
the training courses and teaches you do
not wait until you complete start
getting builders to give you quotes
accept yourselves arrange with estee
agents and getting them in
getting builders in to give them a quote
so literally by the time we
we exchange on the property and complete
it um you know literally it was time for
builders to go in right and you know
this is the importance of of having
training and being trained is because
you know you get the knowledge and you
know there's a process of things
everybody believe in you know just
having a bash but when you've got the
knowledge and the support you're able to
go on to doing things more smoothly i
mean some might say well how did you
just all of a sudden buy that auction
and well i suppose once you've got the
knowledge on how it works it doesn't
matter where you're buying it from right
you know because you've been trained
properly
you know you
are a smart guy you're an action taker
you're a go-getter combine that with
support and training together and then
you've got the ingredients for a
property millionaire like you are now
which is amazing so that first property
what about tenants man how do you manage
a property that's so far away from home
oh it's easy you just have an agent
manager um well i say it's easy
we had someone managing the property at
first um and it was just a total
nightmare
it was really bad literally we had our
tenant complaining
and we end up managing it ourselves but
still paying the the agency a management
fee um yeah we had the tenant on a
whatsapp message and every time
something went wrong they're like
literally um
something this is not right this is not
right um and another issue was
the agency that was looking after the
property was also in collaboration with
the builder that did the work so it was
almost like you were fighting a losing
battle complaining about stuff that was
repaired in the property and
lucky me um it's all about your network
so um we reached out to amanda leeds
yeah i'm sure you might know her the
girl man
yeah we just basically asked you know
if you can recommend like
and let an agent that you know that we
can use um and [ __ ] oh she was like yeah
sure we we've got properties up in
durham um you know you can use our
letting agent so we went home literally
look them up give them a call yeah sure
yeah families we know samuel leads um
and they were literally on the board
boom boom boom i never heard from them
from this time now massive amazing shout
out to what be my home that's correct
i love being mine they manage our
properties and they've done really well
for us so okay so that's the first
property after that you're like now i
can i i i've refinanced i've pulled all
my money back out so that's 66 grand i
got it back so i'm gonna do the same
thing again and then again and that's
what you did right that's correct so i
was hungry about that point um and it's
like i couldn't sleep like at night time
i'm going to sleep like four hours in
the morning and because i'm just looking
for my next opportunity i've got my
courses up i'm still learning and i'm
looking for properties and so i went
across not too far from me i'm not too
far from from you and i've gone across
the mid and head and secured another brr
wow
down the road from here okay what are
the figures how much you pay for it uh
so this one was at auction again and i
bought this one for 155 000. that's
cheap around here exactly yes
it was on my peg right now so i had my
builders that i normally use around my
residential property so i've managed to
refurb that property for twelve thousand
pounds wow
so he bought it for one five five
repurpose 12 says 167 all in refinance
valuation refinance came back at 240
000. no
a training course when my mortgage
broker messaged me saying 180 is going
to be hitting your bank
night so you pulled out all your money
and some that must have been a good
feeling it is an amazing feeling it is
amazing how are you running out
uh so that's been rented out as a
singlet at the moment yeah um obviously
we've been taught to to use different
strategies but that is bringing me
1150 a month so i thought i'm just going
to leave that as it is
1150 there's no need to do anymore what
else have you got going on yes so
obviously i've bought a piece of
landings in vincent now um i'm just
trying to do a bit more development
going to development now and i thought
it's going to be easy enough for me to
start back there so that piece of land
is going to be four luxury apartments of
course it's going to be essay yeah and
that's going to be tailored around
guests coming to saint vincent want to
come on
um and
i'm just looking forward to get started
on that amazing does that mean i'll be
i'll be getting an invite to stay at um
saint vincent it's got your name all
over it yeah you'll be the first guest
so tell me what's the advantage to
service accommodation short stay left
what's the advantage to that as opposed
to traditional long-term mets um i think
for me when looking at essays or service
accommodation the advantage is that you
know it's almost like your rental on
steroids um you know you've got guests
that's going to come into your property
and they're going to go
if i want to get a tenant out i can get
them out straight away um
and also just the cash flow that comes
from it obviously when you've got a
single leg you get less run of it coming
in
and also
you know if you need your property back
then there's obviously a process down we
know how hard it is these days to get a
tenant out whereas an essay is creative
it's exciting and you get a lot of cash
flow out of it um and i suppose that's
why most of my properties going forward
are going to be essays tax advantages
exactly i love that you're now combining
the buyer refurbishing finance with
service accommodation so many tax
benefits to that i'm just furnished
let's you've got coverage on
which of course we're going to great
detail on the training
what's been some of the hard points
because um i'm sure they've been
difficult points i'm sure over the last
year it's not going easy um
what's been the hardest the hardest
moment in the
journey um
i would say
the hardest moment was
i've got to spit out
it's just all been so easy
and to be honest with you i'm not going
to sit here and boss but it's been all
right because i think i've done the
right thing i think of you know
education is the key i've gone through
the training which made a lot of stuff
easy for me and
so i think that's where that was a bit
of a difficult question to answer
because i'm looking for faults whereas
you know followed your program step by
step yeah it was so easy to just follow
and and to execute yeah because the
thing is i get accused of making things
look too easy right so that's why i
always ask my guests and my students to
talk about they always say what's been
hard what's been hard and i'm trying to
just highlight that but i guess if you
if you have found it relatively easy i
guess that's fine as well it's just your
you know your journey and what you found
for it um also
i think having if you compare it to
having a job having a job's hard yes
everything's hard yes you know so it's
like well actually yes it's a bit of
work but how easy was getting that rent
to rent at the training
um so
i mean i'll give you the full story
behind the rent yeah and because i
remember coming up and say samuel i've
just been i just had to run out of the
training because i had a viewing so that
wrench when i secured i secured that
walking into an estee agent and now
there was another academy member we went
to view these properties and literally
we were like well we're here now we
might as well samuel always talks about
walking into letting agent and we've
seen it on his financial freedom
challenges and we're like
let's just do it let's just let's try it
so there was only two letting agents
open at that point because it was around
the christmas season and we walked into
the first one guy was really friendly he
came over to us he sat down we were
really warm towards him and then he said
to her and then we started basically
asking for company let's etc and then he
his face just changed and we went there
we go
and then i just basically asked him said
um you know is it not something that you
do and then he just replied to me when
no not anymore we just go into legal
process at the moment because you know
we've obviously offered a company like
to someone else and
you know and they're basically messed up
um and straight away i was like you know
i just want to apologize on behalf of
that person because the issue that we've
got at the moment is you know people are
not chained properly and they're not
chained from the right sources and
everybody wants to have a bash
and you know
it's not something that you could expect
from us you know we have actually
invested and we've gone to an academy
and learned you know literally all we
need to learn to be able to execute this
correctly we've got loads of other
properties that we're doing among
ourselves and we're doing it
successfully um unfortunately it's not a
discussion he wanted to entertain at
that point but he did take my details
and he said you know if it's something
that you know we're gonna look into
again we will we'll contact you and let
you know
um you know again in you know experience
and changing we always get tall go for
nose um with the expectation of getting
a yes so you know it didn't really knock
us back you know and i think it was
important to actually be there and learn
you know experience that firsthand
things that you tell us as well because
you're always like you know you're going
to get knockbacks you're going to get to
tell those yeah um but you know don't
let it be something that's going to you
know demotivate you yeah anyway we had
one more letting agent to walk into and
we thought
we're going we're going to do it anyway
and so we walked in latin agent was
really nice
and she came over to us we explained you
know what we're looking for
and what we're gonna be doing she said
actually it's really hard at the moment
i haven't got any properties and she
would actually i've got two-bedroom
house that you could have if it works i
said oh okay um you know we we obviously
just if you can give us the address
we'll have a look at the the details we
print some numbers and you know we'll
let you know at first hand if we think
it works and so i went home had a look
at it and it was literally right next to
the hospital in maidenhead and there was
another essay on the same road as well
so i had a good example to analyze you
know what that essay is doing and it's
killing it and if you see the pictures
of the competition
nothing like we're taught i dropped to
an email i said listen i couldn't wait
until the morning so i dropped an email
said
i'd love to have a look around it if you
can let me know if the landlord will be
open to doing it and she reached out to
the landlord she wasn't as open at first
but because this latin agent is
accustomed to doing these type of deals
you know she wasn't you know and that
that language had trust in that letting
agent so it was a bit easier for her to
convince her that you know this could be
a potential long term left for her
exception
so i was at the chain and i got the call
like she's in so i thought
i'm going right now i'm not waiting so i
went across looked at it she was like
there was someone else coming out the
door from viewing the property she's
like i know there's a viewing but i know
you're inquired and i've got you if you
want it
looked around there absolutely not much
to do with it amazing
and i said
we don't need to wait until in the
morning we'll have it so secured it came
back i saw you there and i was like
i gotta tell him i'll go tell him
walked up to you and you were just like
the excitement and you know just just
just having that support all the time
and seeing you i've mentioned to you
before i've had other training providers
before me and you i've had no regrets
training with any of them because i
needed to see and i hope you know other
people don't learn the hard way by
investing badly into other training
providers that don't give them a hundred
percent reason i'm saying this is it's
been absolutely amazing you know in the
academy it's like just having someone to
come back to and just tell someone about
what you've done having a real person to
speak to and you know and just explain
what you've done if you've got any other
questions um and you know if you've got
any issues and just seeing you and being
there being happy being supportive is
just like heartwarming and you know that
just gave me even more confidence to
just go on and do it again and do it and
go and do it again um
it's crazy and as you say like we do
things to the highest standard as well
so if there's one in the road already
that's performing really well and it's
not even to the standard that we're
going to do it um that's massively
exciting talk to me about your wife as
well because i know she's involved so
she's obviously been there and i've been
supporting from day one so massive shout
out to her she's been amazing i am
supporting and she's been to one or two
viewings with me i've brought her to one
of you your courses as well are the free
ones you know me just telling them or
telling her that you know about samuel
and the reason why i'm not there every
day because i'm viewing properties um
you know
she needs to experience it at first time
she needs to come and experience that
energy that you bring yeah and then she
could understand why i'm coming home so
gasps and not sleeping at night so what
would be your biggest advice to someone
that was maybe 12 months behind you that
was looking at getting started didn't
have loads of money um wasn't in a
situation that had loads of property
experience but they were just wanting to
follow in your footsteps my piece of
advice would be just to be get educated
um again you know as i've mentioned
before for someone coming on board and
starting out buying properties at
auctions etc
if you don't have the education and
you're just having a batch it could be
one of the most expensive bus you'll
ever have and so i think at first it's
like any other trade as well you need to
get that education before you go on
further
and once you've got the knowledge you
can go on to do things and and be where
i am now and where other people are and
what's the next steps for the future
then um i'm gonna venture into doing a
bit more deal sourcing i'm gonna be
looking to build my portfolio even
further um i'm gonna be trying to get
back down to the free courses to try and
you know give back to the academy um you
know i've been doing that so far so i'm
gonna keep doing that explaining to
people my situation how i got to where i
got to and you know just advise them you
know you need to get educated there's no
point trying to come to the free ones
only and not trying to educate yourself
even further because once you come on
this train there's no there's no going
back
even at the training programs you know
some people come and they think i'll
take notes no quietly yeah but it's like
no no we're gonna give you a phone and
you're gonna have to call it and call
the landlord
it's kind of like peer pressure you know
and i think that's so important because
if you're around other people that are
winning even on the mastermind calls the
training programs the get-togethers the
parties like when we had that when we
had that christmas party how many people
like 120 people but pretty much
everybody in the room is doing deals
making money there's millionaires
there's multi-millionaires when you're
in that environment hanging and
celebrating with those people it's so
it's it's so easy to just to just be
successful always if you're just at home
on your own yeah watching youtube videos
getting rejected suddenly it's so hard
it's hard to succeed yeah definitely and
from my background you know it's it's
not been easy um you know because as
you've said it before when you start
coming up in life and you start doing
amazing things it's almost like there's
an imbalance in terms of your network um
and you know there's been times in the
past where
you know people are just looking at you
differently only because you're being
successful
um and i remember at one point i was
like just
looking at you going on you know the
things that you normally hear because it
there's always there's always a bit of
negative about you and i think you're
going to get that on your way up and i
think it's even then more important to
surround yourself with people that's got
a common interest and goals and like you
said coming to the christmas party
everybody was just in their element we
were around each other everybody's doing
deals you speak to the next person yeah
i've just secured this i've just secured
that
i could just be in that environment all
day long yes
i think the things i think the things
that successful people have in common
number one is they get trained they get
the knowledge that's good number two is
mentality
the reason this guy's successful is
because of his mindset is because of his
successful mentality so you know what
let me tell you something if you're
feeling um if you're feeling like you
can't succeed right now if you're
feeling like oh it's all right for them
it's right for them let me just say i'm
believing in you right now watching this
there's a reason that you're on this
youtube channel there's a reason that
you're still watching and i want to see
you win so if you want to succeed in
property if you want help from myself or
from my team then comment down to a
property investors crash course that's
where it starts i'll leave a link in the
description i really hope to see you win
this year in 2022 god bless you i'm
rooting for you i'll never know for ya
[Music]
hey